it is a momentous historic night no
doubt give us a sense of how you're
feeling three words to sum up this
evening well what would be relieved I'm
relieved that we're ending the division
in our country I'm also pleased that's
another word that we can get on with our
lives and I'm excited about the
opportunities that lie ahead as a
sovereign nation obviously the the Prime
Minister has pre-recorded a statement
we'll get to hear that after 10 o'clock
this evening he talked about new
beginnings he talked about a new era he
talked about a new chapter in the
history of our country
he talked also about unity so what is
the message to the people of Britain to
the people of the UK now from this
government that's right in the we have a
cabinet in Sunderland today and the
Prime Minister you repeated that message
which I think there'll be a message from
him later this evening to the country
but it is about this way we're moving on
as a country we are ending this chapter
that we've had with the EU and we've
achieved a lot together but we're
opening this new exciting chapter where
we will still be having a very good
partnership with our European friends
working together in many ways but also
as a sovereign nation being able to do
so much more yet as well as working with
our European friends we can open up new
trade agreements around the world we can
have your laws and regulations for
businesses that suit our businesses we
can do so much more and I think that's
what makes it so exciting brexit is done
will be the message we've had take back
control get brick sit down clearly it's
not the case that brexit is done the
months ahead will be tricky with the
trade negotiations
I know Michael Gove was the person
dispatched today to tell people that
actually divergence is the name of the
game that there will be friction at the
borders and I put it to you how many
weeks of people queuing for hours at
Britain's borders before that policy
unravels
well that breaks it will be done tonight
so in about a couple of hours brexit
will be done we will be outside of the
EU of course for this year we've got
their transition period and we're going
to use that time to get a Canada style
free-trade agreement with our European
friends I'm confident we'll get that and
fantastic for us it will be good for
them but also there's so much else to do
you know in that election we had last
month we were very clear about the need
to level up the spread opportunity in
our country wherever you go like in
Sunderland today there's talent
everywhere we are blessed with talent
but there's not enough opportunity so we
want to spread opportunity across the
country that means investing more in
infrastructure it means investing more
in skills you're getting rid of new
regulations that that might be holding
business back and working as a country
where our economy can get even stronger
and we can spread opportunity everywhere
so there's a lot of challenges that
still lie ahead
yes apologies for interrupting you know
economy gets stronger
if trade is held up though does it if
indeed those goods that need to be
delivered to supermarkets are held up in
calais how do you guarantee to people
that the trade that you are envisaging
under a Canada deal will not lead to
friction that disrupts the economy in
this country but I am very confident and
it's not it's not just me and let's look
at business let's look at what's
actually happening yeah since the
election that we've just had we have
business that has got off the fence and
started investing again business after
business I've talked to many of them
since the election and confidence is
back in Britain me just last week the
IMF upgraded a growth forecast for
countries across the world and they
forecast that this year the UK will grow
faster than Germany than France than
Italy than Japan they've they've taken
into account that we're gonna have a
free trade agreement a new way of doing
business with the rest of Europe so you
know there's lots of excitement out
there and we can really move ahead and I
can really see that confidence
throughout the country yes we had Mark
Carney downgrading the growth forecast
obviously for the UK
only earlier today talking about the
Canada deal a nice off-the-shelf model
that people can understand the problem
is that the Treasury's own forecasts had
said it would mean a loss of four point
nine percent to the British economy over
15 years compared to staying in the
European Union and it doesn't include
services that is what more than 80
percent
of our economy well I mean first of all
you just mentioned downgrading forecast
by summon and the the point there is
that there you name you find me a
country anywhere in the world that
hasn't had its forecasts downgraded in
in in recent weeks the last few months
and that's because there is a problem
for the global economy but Britain is
doing well we want it to do better and
that of course means our services
industries our financial services
industry for example is hugely important
in terms of the job and wealth creation
for everyone and it's something that I
know will continue to go from strength
to strength as we leave the EU we strike
a new trade agreement let's talk about
fishing if we can it seems to be the
first great stumbling block that the UK
government and the European Union will
come up against just naught point naught
4 percent of the economy here in the UK
and yet absolutely crucial to the French
president emmanuel micro making clear
that without good trade in fishing that
the rest of it you can forget about
180,000 jobs across the EU block in
fishing alone why are you deciding to
look after fishing at the expense of a
trade deal if you know it's not about
looking after fishing or anything else
it's about looking after Britain and
looking after our interests and that's
what taking back control means by
leaving the EU leaving the common market
leaving the customs that Union and all
of that it means that you know we won't
be rule takers and we can do things that
are in the interests of the United
Kingdom of course we'll work with our
European friends we'll strike that
free-trade agreement but the rules that
we follow will be our own rules so when
it comes to fishing we will take control
of our of our waters when it comes to
financial services we'll continue to
work with the EU countries as well as
countries outside the EU and remain very
strong in that sector your other
countries have have managed to not be in
the EU and be incredibly successful
economies and there's no reason why we
can't do that and the idea is to have
simultaneous trade deals and
negotiations underway with the
you with the u.s. with Japan with
Australia and with New Zealand is it we
are starting negotiations as well as the
EU as you say we will be beginning
discussions with our friends in the
United States with Australia Japan of
course and it's important because now we
have this freedom we can strike these
trade deals and of course they have to
work for those countries they have to
work for us but it means that we can
open up to trade to the benefit of
British consumers and the British
economy in a way we couldn't do before
hopefully you'll have a few job adverts
out to get trade negotiators if you're
having them all at the same time we have
actually hired many of the last couple
of years so I'm more than confident we
can handle them all at once well I don't
have the exact number it's not my
department but I know that a lot has
been done and I'm confident we've got
the resources in place to have all these
negotiations at once ok it's going to be
a hard task certainly isn't it do you
have any nerves do you have any nerves
that you can't take the country together
can you make a promise to the nation
tonight that for the sake of the 48% of
people for the sake of exporters in this
country for the sake of retired people
in southern Spain for example who want
to get their medicines that you and the
government will work doggedly and
determinedly
to get a deal with the European Union we
will not waste an ounce of energy in
getting a deal that's what we will be
absolutely focused on in terms of
getting our Canada style free-trade
agreement so brexit will be done tonight
we will get the free trade agreement I'm
very confident of that let me just say
you know tonight is it's not a night for
triumphalism it's it's a night to bring
the country together and for that the 48
percent that didn't vote in that
historic referendum
it's also worth recording many of those
people you know they're Democrats and
they they accepted the result the
referendum they've embraced it and the
whole country now has an opportunity to
end division move together as one nation
just one final thought if you don't mind
while I've got you we know you've
started asking government departments
for 5% of savings well yet in terms of
infrastructure spending you have decided
that hs2 is a good idea
what made you change your mind well
first of all I am NOT going to quit hs2
I've made no decision yet it's a
decision for the entire government and
we're discussing it in government when
we've made the decision where we will we
will be clear about what that is so no
decision yet but in terms of finding
savings in government a government
should always be looking for savings to
make sure that every penny on behalf of
taxpayers is being properly spent and
that's the job of the Treasury and
that's something we take very seriously
so we can take all that funding that we
have from taxpayers and make sure it's
absolutely focused on our central
mission which is levelling up across the
country spreading opportunity making
sure no part of this country is left
behind